look at these youtubers they all made
all this money
by going like what are they what are
they review serials these people
they're trillionaires because they're
because that that's
they realize they're like smarter than
all of us we're all trying to figure out
the world they're like i like applejacks
that's the move
that's the move half of these youtubers
like i'm on a plane now
people are like i planned planes but
that's it they're actually right
the tick tockers are actually right
that and maybe i've been in la for too
long but that's when you start
when you look at the the state of the
world
and you see a bunch of kids like
and i go oh they're right
that's what social media should be i'm
doing a dumb little dance
and not a 300 comment thread about trade
on facebook which you don't know
anything about you don't know what it
is that's when you know you're you're
crazy
you know that and crazy in in the true
sense of the word it's like
at a certain point you got to give it to
some of these youtubers who were just
like
the world is over it is fallen
and i just want to do things that will
pass the time for people
so they don't start militias and blow
each other's brains out
and that's that's the best version of
youtube are people who go
hey don't start a militia let's talk
about candy
don't join isis why because i'm gonna
give someone a lamborghini
okay that's the best version of that
i'm gonna open a gift don't kill your
wife
watch me open a gift you go oh good
hey don't put that cat in the microwave
there's pokemon cards here
we're gonna play a game how many kids
don't shoot up schools because they get
to watch
david dobrik give people lamborghinis
probably a lot
so i'm not against any of that i think
it's good
it's just a wasting the time that's what
we have to do
we just have to run out the clock you
see
[Music]
it's running at the we're just running
at the clock we're only here for a
little while we're only here forever
you're not gonna solve it you dumb [ __ ]
i think you're gonna solve it the
problems aren't even
new they've been around forever the
problems must be
real problems huh
so we're just running out the clock
we're just trying to prevent an
incredible explosion of
physical violence that will bleed into
every aspect of american life
and what do we do and how do we do that
we we run out the clock with
garbage [ __ ] i wish this stuff was a
little better
i'd prefer a few more woody allen movies
a few thinkers
but the country doesn't want that so
it's okay what am i gonna tell the
country
what they want they wanna they wanna
watch what they wanna watch
i make it a table guy make it into
hey don't worry about whose skull is
what shape watch me sand the table
we're running out the clock here
all the art you consume including maybe
even this
show is running out the clock
and it's important to do because if you
don't do it the demons are going to win